or ce qui se passe c'est que mes 1200
euros monsieur ils n'ont pas augmenté
depuis 10 ans alors moi je me retrouve
avec une retraite pareil que quelqu'un
qui a jamais bossé quoi parce que moi
j'ai des gens autour de moi dans mon
village ils ont jamais travaillé ils ont
900 euros par mois c'est ça
ne me concerne pas moi les gens ils font
ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas mon problème
mais j'estime que moi j'ai eu des
enfants j'ai travaillé en même temps et
mes enfants sont tous contribuables je
veux dire alors comment se fait-il qu'il
y ait des gens qui n'aient jamais bossé
qui n'ont pas d'enfants qui n'en ont
jamais fait pour devenir des
contribuables et qui gagnent une
retraite alors ça faut me poser la
question maintenant il y a aussi une
autre question que je vais vous poser je
pense que Cyril m'en donne
l'autorisation les figurez-vous que je
paye quand même les cotisations retraite
la CG sur mon petit boulot qui vient en
complément moi j'en ai besoin pour payer
les activités sportives de mes
petits-enfants parce que malgré le Pass
de pour jouer au rugby pour un gosse
c'est 200 euros dans mon village
j'habite un petit village profond de la
France où il y a rien il y a pas on est
obligé de prendre la voiture pour
n'importe quoi donc moi si vous voulez
c'est très dur pour nous je ne peux pas
acheter de poisson je ne peux pas
acheter tout le temps de la viande de
temps en temps j'emmène des petits au
McDo manger le Happy Meal 4,95 et c'est
tout la sortie vous comprenez et j'ai
travaillé toute ma vie voilà alors moi
il y a quand même quelque chose que je
vais vous poser je pense que tout le
monde serait d'accord et Cyril aussi
comment se fait-il que les sénateurs les
députés et tous ces gens là ils aient
des retraites spéciales il parle nous
alors
on va peut-être commencer on va
peut-être commencer par le dernier point
si vous voulez alors la retraite
spéciale en fait c'est pas une retraite
spéciale des parlementaires c'est ce
qu'on appelle un régime autonome ce qui
vous fait une belle jambe parce que vous
allez dire c'est pareil bon en fait
l'Assemblée nationale est députée à
chaque fois qu'il y a une réforme des
retraites il s'applique il se l'applique
seulement la Constitution fait que parce
qu'il doit y avoir une autonomie des
parlementaires par rapport au
gouvernement c'est la séparation des
pouvoirs on ne peut pas dans un texte de
loi classique comme la loi des retraites
décidé pour les députés de changer la
retraite d'accord il faudrait ce qu'on
appelle une loi organique et une loi
différente qui est compliquée à faire
adopter en revanche que je peux vous
dire c'est que les députés ont déjà acté
et décider qu'il s'appliquerait les
mêmes modalités de la réforme des
retraites que celles qui vont être
amenées à voter dans quelques jours donc
soyez rassurés de ce point de vue là les
députés ils la majorité essentielle a
fait ce choix de s'appliquer à elle-même
ce qu'elle demande aux Français premier
point les sénateurs ça peut être
différent ils ne se sont pas encore
prononcés on n'y a pas la majorité je
peux pas parler à leur place mais je
veux bien le relayer la question parce
que je suis assez d'accord avec
rendez-vous pour dire que les
parlementaires ils doivent être logés à
la même enseigne le reste des Français
ça c'est le premier point premier point
exemple arrêté
alors ensuite vous m'avez parlé de la
retraite de ceux qui sont à 960 euros
c'est à dire qu'ils ont l'ASPA le
minimum vieillesse Josiane je voudrais
vous parler de quelques personnes que
j'ai eu à rencontrer comme ministre des
Solidarités et puis quand j'étais à
Orchies dans le Pas-de-Calais il y a
deux semaines à la rencontre d'une
vingtaine de retraités qui ont des
petites pensions un peu comme vous
il y en avait il y avait là-bas trois ou
deux ou trois femmes c'était des femmes
qui touchaient le minimum enfin le
minimum de 960 euros alors faut savoir
d'abord que si elles ont du patrimoine
au-dessus au dessus de 40 000 euros
l'état récupère au moment de la
succession ce qu'il a donné pour
permettre à quelqu'un de vivre à peu
près au niveau du seuil de pauvreté
d'accord avec la réforme des retraites
on va passer cette récupération de 40
000 à 100.000 euros c'est à dire toutes
les personnes qui ont moins de 100000
euros de patrimoine on va effectivement
leur donner leur compléter leurs revenus
jusqu'à hauteur de 960 euros parce que
on considère qu'une personne âgée en
dessous de 960 euros on vit pas on ne
vit pas et on la suit
Josiane les personnes que j'ai vu qui
touchaient ces 960 euros les trois que
j'ai vu c'était ça va peut-être vous
parler ça va peut-être parler aux
artisans qui sont là au commerçants des
conjoints de collaboratrices vous savez
ce que c'est oh oui bah c'était les
secrétaires de leur mari commerçant
médecin ou autre et quand on fait bosser
toute leur vie mais qui était pas
déclaré et donc au moment de la retraite
on leur a dit madame vous n'avez pas
cotisé vous n'étiez pas déclaré donc il
y a pas de retraite et moi j'en ai vu
moi ça me fend le cœur à chaque fois je
veux dire un truc ça me folker on peut
pas les retrouver on pourrait on peut
pas faire une mesure moi j'étais posé la
question de dire est-ce qu'on peut pas
les rattraper dans la loi mais par
définition comme elles sont pas connues
du fisc et ben on peut pas démontrer que
c'est bien cette situation là mais c'est
pour vous donner un exemple de personne
ensuite vous avez beaucoup
d'agriculteurs tous les minimum
vieillesse et qui n'ont pas cotisé
suffisamment non pas en termes d'années
ou de dureté du labeur mais parce que
leurs revenus étaient insuffisant pour
leur permettre d'avoir une retraite
supérieure à 1000 euros et donc moi
j'assume parfaitement ce mécanisme de
solidarité et même on l'a passé il était
à 800 et quelques euros on l'a passé à
900 puis là il est monté à 960 euros
parce que
je suis aussi l'augmentation du coût de
la vie ensuite Josiane pour ce qui vous
concerne il y a des éléments que vous
devriez regarder de près dans la réforme
des retraites parce que vous êtes en
situation de cumul emploi retraite c'est
la deuxième question la deuxième
remarque que vous avez fait et vous avez
raison vous dites alors que je touche ma
retraite avec ma retraite elle bouge pas
j'ai pris un boulot mais je cotise pour
la retraite sur le boulot ben ça le
cumul emploi retraite on le facilite on
le simplifie on le rend plus juste avec
la loi c'est à dire que les retraités
qui conserveront une activité à côté et
bien on va simplifier et supprimer des
cotisations qui aujourd'hui leur diminue
le petit pécule qui se font à côté ça va
être ça va dépendre du niveau de revenu
je vais pas vous dire de bêtises
là-dessus parce que le texte de loi est
en cours d'examen au Parlement mais
grosso modo sachez que l'état d'esprit
c'est de ne plus vous forcer à cotiser
pour un truc que vous ne toucherez pas
donc vous voyez ça va plutôt dans le bon
sens et un autre élément sur la réforme
des retraites parce que je j'insiste et
je comprends et on va peut-être en
discuter et peut-être des gens qui vont
me dire qu'ils sont pas du tout d'accord
etc aucun problème j'assume qu'on puisse
en discuter juste un point sur lequel
j'insiste c'est que pour les gens qui
sont déjà retraités il y a que des
gagnants
avec la réforme parce que moi quand
j'étais député et sous la gauche et dans
le mandat précédent on a été amené ça
vous parlera à sous indexer les pensions
de retraite c'est-à-dire qu'on les
augmenter moins que l'inflation voir à
geler les pensions de retraite pour
essayer de trouver l'équilibre financier
du système mais là comme on arrive à
équilibrer le système en demandant aux
gens de travailler un peu plus longtemps
par cette mécanisme de solidarité on
sait qu'on aura plus besoin de geler ou
de sous-indexer les pensions donc vos
pensions je tiens elles vont augmenter
et après vous avez la dernière situation
qui sont des retraités qui gagnent un
peu moins que vous mais qui ont
travaillé une carrière complète
c'est-à-dire qu'on bossait les 40 années
qui ont et qui ont avaient un salaire à
peu près au niveau SMIC et qui se
retrouve avec 1050 ou 1100 euros par
mois eux on va les monter à 1200 euros
par mois c'est à dire qu'on va ce qu'on
appelle la retraite minimale avec la
réforme des retraites pour justement
augmenter un peu le niveau de vie des
retraités avec 1300 vous en sortez pas
parce que vous avez deux petits enfants
mais il y a beaucoup de retraités qui
avec 1100 s'en sortent encore moins
voilà vous êtes très courageuse d'avoir
pris un job à côté ça me fera un peu le
cœur parce que quand on a bossé toute sa
vie qu'on a cotisé toute sa vie la
retraite c'est le moment du repos et ce
repos il est mérité donc sachez que l'un
des objectifs de cette réforme au-delà
du fait d'équilibrer le financement
c'est aussi de faire en sorte que nos
retraités vivent mieux dans notre pays